quelques questions au dr gaston de
serres de l'institut national de santé
publique du québec dr de serres bonsoir
bonsoir alors la quatrième taureau rouge
c'est pour qui en fait parce que là on
voit que on nous va toutes les tranches
d'âge qui devrait y aller
le comité sur l'immunisation
et misson ses recommandations la semaine
dernière disant que les gens à qui
recommandait la vaccination avec cette
deuxième dose de rappel ou la quatrième
dose depuis le début aux gens de 80 ans
et plus qui vivent dans la communauté et
aux personnes vivant en ch sld et dans
les airs payeurs les ressources
intermédiaires et ressources de type
familial il y avait aussi les gens
immunosupprimées maintenant le comité
sur l'immunisation disait si le
ministère veut élargir à des groupes
d'âge plus jeune c'est possible on n'est
pas sûr du bénéfice qu'on aura avec la
vexation des gens plus jeunes parce que
des gens même chez les gens de 80 ans et
plus on voyait une très très bonne
persistance de la protection donné par
la troisième dose contre les
hospitalisations mais quelqu'un de 65 à
63 ans 67 ans qui est en relativement
bonne forme vous lui dites alesi ou
attendez pour la quatrième
ce qui est dit actuellement par le
directeur national de santé publique
c'est que la dose elle est disponible
pour ceux qui ont entre 60 et 79 ans qui
veulent venir la chercher mais ce n'est
pas une recommandation forte comme on le
fait pour les gens de 80 ans et plus
donc à la halle exemple que vous me
donnez de quelqu'un qui serait en bonne
santé et qu'ils auraient reçues ces
droits aux doses c'est pas une grande
nécessité le d'avoir cette dose
additionnel sommes maintenant d'autres
d'autant plus que la vague actuelle va
durer quelques semaines mais
le rendez vous que les gens vont avoir
on va peut-être arriver au moment où la
vague va est en décroissance d'accès à
ce moment deux évidemment le bénéfice
devient très très faible de la quatrième
dose on est probablement mieux
d'attendre à l'automne alors que l'on
s'attend à voir une remontée des corps
et un éloignement depuis la deuxième la
troisième dose qui me rendent une dose
de rappel beaucoup plus intéressant pas
de précipitation si on est en forme
sonate alors ou de 60 ans si on a eu la
coved puis beaucoup beaucoup de gens
vous le savez encore mieux que moi mon
autour de nous que qu'on l'en qui ont eu
la coved est-ce qu'on est protégé donc s
convenir air recevoir la quatrième dose
bientôt
dans le même avis du comité sur
l'immunisation de la semaine dernière on
dit bien quelqu'un qui vient de faire la
couv il donc qui a été vaccinée avec
deux doses et qui a fait la commune
depuis l'arrivée de la vague au micro
cette personne là est bien protégé et si
elle veut recevoir une dose additionnel
pour avoir sa troisième dogs l'on lui
dit de ne pas y aller à vendre ou en moi
donc c'est pas qu'elle doit y aller au
plus tard dans trois mois si on dit vous
êtes bien protégé si vous voulez malgré
tout avoir une dose n'est n'y allez pas
avant tout on attendait 3 mois si vous
avez la coved même si vous n'avez pas eu
la troisième dose
est ce que docteur de serre sur sion en
terminant se projette un presque y aura
comme ça des 5e 6e 7e dose advitam
eternam
je pense qu'on aura pas des 6e 7e 8e
noah 03 moore par contre il est probable
qu'on aura avec à chaque saison
hivernale de la vaccination pour se
protéger contre le covan au virus mais
une vaccination qui ciblera les gens à
haut risque et n'ont pas nécessairement
la salle de la population c'est ce que
je retiens de l'entrevue si vous êtes à
risque au risque évidemment né à risques
c'est le moment d'aller dans cette
parade la 4e d'eau sinon il n'y a pas de
presse d'autant plus où j'ai fait la
queue vide docteur de serre merci
beaucoup à la prochaine